it's good to see you all
let's have a cabinet meeting
really thank you
for what you all are doing
we've got a lot more good things to do
as well
back in july
uh
i signed as you all know an executive
order uh
to uh promote competition
and build uh
build an economy that works for
everybody not just a few
and competition results in lower prices
for families
competition results in fair wages for
workers
and as you all know competition
encourages companies to innovate
and but what we've seen over the last
few decades is less competition
more concentration
that literally holds economy back
and in too many industries a handful of
giant companies dominate dominate the
entire market
and we see it in big ag i need not tell
the sector of agriculture that he's
forgotten more about this than i know
and big tech big pharma the list goes on
and uh rather than competing for
customers they're consuming their
competitors and
rather than
doing what they should be doing they're
doing the opposite having a negative
impact
all told
between generating higher prices and
lower wages
lack of competition costs the median
american family household according to a
study done at ny at the nyu
5 000 a year
the median
income family
my executive order is changing that as
everyone at this table knows
it includes it included 72 specific
actions for federal agencies to take and
help restore competition in our economy
it includes creating a competition
council y'all
and uh comprise the cabinet members and
heads of several
independent agencies to coordinate and
monitor our progress
all across the entire federal government
in six months since i issued the order
we've met every deadline that my order
called for so far
and uh here are just three examples
the right to repair sounds kind of silly
saying it that way but it's what we call
it the right to repair is as literal
too many areas if you don't own a
product
if you assume if you own a product from
a smartphone to a tractor
you don't have the freedom to choose how
or where to repair that item you
purchased
it's broke
well what do i do about it if it's broke
you had to go to the dealer and you had
to pay the dealer's cost the dealer's
price
if you tried to get it fixed you've
tried to fix it yourself
some manufacturers actually would void
the warranty when they sold the vehicle
sold the product to you
or disable the features on that product
they sold to you
denying the right to repair raises
prices for consumers
means independent repair shops can't
compete for your business
and my experience my executive order
announced that support for the right to
repair
rather right after i issued my order i
was pleased to see the federal trade
commission
unanimously announced it would ramp up
unanimously announced would ramp up
enforcement against illegal repair
restrictions
that was allowed by major companies to
or by voluntarily agreeing to change
their restrictions on repairs
um and actually
and what's happened was a lot of these
companies said you're right we're going
to voluntarily do it you don't have to
order us to do it and voluntarily said
we'll do it
for example apple and microsoft are
changing their policies
so folks will be able to repair their
phones and laptops themselves
although i'm not sure i know how to do
that
i when i have any problem my phone i
call my daughter
but it's going to make it easy for
millions of americans to repair their
electronics instead of paying an arm and
a leg to repair or just throwing the
device out
hearing aids
roughly 48 million people suffer from
hearing loss in america 48 million
but to get a hearing aid folks have to
get go see a specialist and then get a
prescription
and then they pay thousands of dollars
for a pair of hearing aids
but the big part is why only that's a
big part of why only one in five people
who could benefit from a hearing aid
actually use one
and so my competition executive order
changes that
in october the food and drug
administration released a new proposal
rule that would make it possible for
hearing aids to be sold over the counter
without a prescription
we expect this is going to lower costs
for hearing aids from thousands of
dollars to literally to hundreds of
dollars saving people's hundreds and
hundreds of dollars
and and people will can pick them up at
a local pharmacy saving time and money
and helping the tens of million people
with hearing loss who don't have hearing
aids now third area mergers
in too many industries big companies big
companies
can use their power to squeeze out
smaller competitors stifle new
competition
raise prices reduce the choice for
customers and exploit their workers
well i've said it before
capitalism without competition
is
is not capitalism
it's exploitation
so the department of justice and other
agencies with oversight authority have
ramped up their efforts to scrutinize
these mergers
it includes challenging or blocking
mergers that are bad for the economy and
your pocketbooks for example
the department of justice just took
action to block a mega merger that would
have resulted in two brokerages
dominating the insurance industry which
would result in customers having fewer
choices
higher prices and lower quality services
the bottom line this isn't just about
quick wins it's about reversing decades
of concentration that have hurt workers
consumers and small businesses it didn't
happen any one time it's been over a
period of time now a long time
this is just the beginning though
in the coming weeks and months americans
can expect to see
more more protections for farmers and
ranchers
selling products like beef pork and
poultry more options and better prices
for consumers
more clarity in the actual price you'll
pay for high-speed internet services and
airline tickets
we're also going to keep pushing on
other priorities and from my executive
order like addressing the non-compete
clauses that affect one in five workers
one in five workers have to sign a
non-compete clause it it it stunned me
but that's how
this as brian will do this how this came
about really this whole competitive
council i knew what was going on but
when i realized how many people
out there with no special insight to
having access to patents or anything
else had to sign a non-compete clause
people making hourly wages
all designed to keep prices down for
keep wages down and prices up
but one in five workers had to give and
gave them the company the power over
their careers
the bottom line is our economy shouldn't
be about people working for capitalism
it should be about capitalism working
for people for everyone now i'm going to
turn this over to brian so we can get
this meeting started but again thank
each and every one of you here on this
council i really mean it you know i
think even when we decided to do this
council
some of you you all thought it was a
good idea but i'll be i'm i'd be
surprised if some of you didn't go whoa
i didn't realize how restrictive some of
this was how respectful some of this was
but you're going to make a difference in
ordinary people's lives
ordinary people's lives going to make a
difference so anyway brian the floor is
yours
could you give us a brief update on your
call with european leaders on what's
happening in ukraine today
the only reason i don't like doing this
is you never report on why i've called a
meeting
and this is really important i had a
very very very good meeting total
unanimity with all the european leaders
we'll talk about it later thank you
thank you
why are you sending 8 500 troops to
ukraine possibly
will you take questions on inflation
then
thank you
thank you
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
stupid
you